[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Jake Decker and I'm here with
Ben djenka and we actually got a little
bit of a surprise if you don't know by
now piranha plant came to super smash
bros a little bit early he was supposed
to come in February but handed upcoming
end of January yeah I I wasn't entirely
prepared for how much I was actually
gonna end up enjoying him they did a
very good job of making them a fun
character with a lot of interesting
mechanics that I don't think a lot of
other characters have yeah he's got some
super weird moves his specials in
particular I think like his most of all
of his specials I think his most basic
is his recovery which he just uses his
his Leafs as a propeller and flight but
you can also deal some good damage with
that and it can knock people back pretty
well like I found myself angling it as I
recovered and I'd if I was playing
multiplayer I could like knock a few
people out of the way yeah it's really
wild how it's got very good like
vertical recovery but also if you turn
enough it's got very strong like
horizontal recovery or just horizontal
movement which is really really cool
yeah and then but I think more
interesting are his side being down be a
side special down special I guess first
we can talk about his side special which
to me I think is one of the weirder
moves in Sparrows because it deals a lot
of damage it's it's just off the bat
it's really weird like having my mind
have to deal with the charge move being
put on like a side special yeah that
didn't mess with my mind is when we kind
of into it it does a lot of damage it
covers a lot of area and it doesn't
knock anyone back it like you can just
stand there you could be at like 300
damage or whatever and you could just
take it stand there yeah but if you're
stuck from beginning to end it'll be
like 50 damage yeah it's it's wild how
much damage it does yeah and I found at
least what I've been doing when I play
piranha plant is I will drop that at the
edge first yeah sorry I know a lot of
people don't like that but if someone
doesn't have a lot of damage and you
throw at the edge they're gonna have to
go through that yeah they're gonna have
to either jump up high over it or take
something from it by just going into it
it's yeah and you can also use it to
like cover yourself to you know like you
can throw it down and they could be
avoiding it you could just sprint
through before they notice
and go for the attack like the short hop
attack or something like that oh if you
if you play with items on imagine if
there's like like a Smash Ball on the
ground or an assist trophy just drop
that on there and no one will want to go
near it yeah speaking of which I haven't
even seen his final smash yet Oh Petey
piranha comes out and starts swinging
his cages around from the first relay
role and the Subspace Emissary and then
just like smacks them down it sang yeah
see I like never play with items or
final smashes so I don't typically see
those unless I have to do I got you
covered I could tell you what happens
it's really cool yeah it's actually
really interesting too cuz weird things
can happen with Petey piranha and that
he can fall off the stage if you call
him out like in the air like over the
edge is that it he'll just try to drop
he just drops and that's it it's yeah
nothing happens it's real wild happen to
me a couple of times very embarrassing
don't recommend it but then moving on to
his down special which is also pretty
wild I think because you hiding your
little pot or your pipe and you're kind
of invulnerable it seems like I can take
a good amount of damage before you
really get knocked out of it and then
depending on how long you hold it
determines how far he'll stretch his
neck yeah and you can also angle that so
if you're like flat on the ground you
can tilt right or left and so far I
found this move super useful and
catching opponents off guard yeah
especially in multiplayer because it
comes out very very quickly and it's he
recording inside of the pot or whatever
he's so small that it's real hard to
pick him apart yeah it almost looks like
you're just like yeah laying down you
know like holding down yeah to lay down
as you would with like King DVD or
something like yeah it's also I really
appreciate that if you're on the ground
and you use it and you commit to one
side you can't like flip the pocket yeah
so you're stuck having to come out the
one one side but however one thing I
found is that if you recover with it or
if you if you're in the middle of
recovering and you use that someone
who's ledge guarding you can rotate it
360 degrees yeah if you need well not
three just I think you can do one 180
degrees I think you can drop facedown
but you don't have a lot of time like
you'll get kicked out eventually but you
can use that to angle yourself to where
they're ledge guarding yeah just get
them and then you and then use your up B
to recover and and if they're if they're
quick and they're able to get back in
you end up cutting them with the leaves
anyway it's a
time and then the last thing is his
neutral B which is neutral special which
is also pretty interesting too because
you fire a spike ball up in the air and
then you can decide which way you want
to go I figured it's good for people who
do that thing where they fall as far as
they can and then recover up so people
can't burn them with like a short hop
air attack downward or something like
that but if you do that and they go
really low and you just drop that spike
ball over if you hit them it's pretty
devastating it's a lot like Simon's axe
it's very very hard and I like how
depending on the height that it is while
you're initially holding it you'll
actually throw it further or higher like
the horn will change so there's a lot of
kind of things that go into how you
would use that move yeah so those are
your special moves his his basic attacks
seem pretty decent they're pretty par
for the course you know like they have a
reasonable range he's pretty quick yeah
how powerful is plant yeah in a pot you
know but yeah and he also has those
little feet yeah jumps that are good and
he runs with his tongue out he's got a
great aesthetic yeah which i think is
definitely one of the stronger points
mm-hmm is a character yeah I think they
had to hike him considering how like
basic he seems most importantly though
with piranha plant is that if you
swallow him as Kirby Kirby has a little
piranha plant yeah adorable sicknesses
arms like through the mouth and it's
it's really good it's very good
top top two transformations for Kirby's
for sure anyways thank you guys for
watching those are some tips we have for
piranha plant if there's anything we
missed or anything you can think of let
us know in the comments below and if you
haven't played him yet give him a try
he's a good addition
[Applause]
[Music]
you